si efectivamente una ruptura de la
coalición una coalición muy heterogénea
como lo recordó que ha mostrado
dificultades digamos para
acordarse Para apoyar una agenda de
muchas reformas que pretende pasar al
gobierno Entonces vamos a vamos a ver si
finalmente entonces con esta crisis
el presidente Petro logra reorganizar
sus tropas y una coalición que que le
funcione y Cuáles han sido las
diferencias y reconciliables adentro de
esta coalición que ahora se rompe
Bueno hay tres grandes reformas que
quiere pasar al gobierno colombiano una
reforma a la salud Una reforma a las
pensiones al sistema pensional y una
reforma laboral en este momento la
primera de las tres la reforma de la
salud se está negociando y este anuncio
de reorganización del gobierno
interviene justo después de que la
reforma de la salud pasará
el primer debate en el congreso pero de
manera muy ajustada con
unos votos de los partidos tradicionales
que apoyan a la coalición que que le
faltaron al gobierno en este en este
primer debate y y ahí de ahí entonces la
la crisis ahí que se que se abre eh con
este anuncio del presidente y
precisamente el presidente anunció la
necesidad de formar un gobierno de
emergencia porque ahora llega esta
emergencia y no cuando asumió el poder
en agosto
yo creo que al principio el presidente
trató de formar una coalición de la
forma más tradicional negociando con Los
jefes de los partidos que que iban a ser
parte de esta coalición esos jefes de
partidos han mostrado finalmente que no
le caminaban a la agenda reformista del
gobierno y ahora pues yo creo que la
estrategia del gobierno va a estar va a
ser de tratar de
de de de de de de negociar concepto
redes de estos partidos de pronto más
afines a estas reformas no sé muy bien
que se entenderá por gobierno de
emergencia en este caso Yo creo que la
el tema ahí sigue siendo un tema de cómo
lograr un equilibrio que que permita
tener este apoyo en el congreso el pacto
histórico el partido del presidente no
tiene ni el cuarto del Congreso que lo
apoya Entonces se necesita una coalición
para sacar adelante esta agenda
reformista muy muy ambiciosa y por el
momento del gobierno no lo ha logrado y
le pido que reformas tendría que hacer
el gobierno que reformas dentro del
gabinete Petro tendría que hacer para
poder llevar a cabo estas reformas tan
ambiciosas como usted dice qué roles
serían clave
Bueno ahí
se especula mucho Sobre qué podría ser
la composición de un nuevo gabinete se
piensa mucho en un reemplazo de los
ministros que son cuotas digamos de
estos partidos tradicionales que apoyan
el gobierno el ministro de transporte la
ministra de vivienda la ministra de las
tics por ejemplo entonces que son
oficialmente las cuotas de esos tres
partidos entonces estaremos muy atentos
sobre todo a ver si son reemplazados y
si lo son si si es por gente que también
pueda de algún modo representar o esos
partidos o sectores de estos partidos